[Musik]
ja arbeiten zb in der betreuung sind den
ganzen tag in der stadt unterwegs
kriegen von den kassen weil wir
sozusagen mit den kassen zusammen
arbeiten in unseren preis für die kunden
ist der benzinpreis schon inbegriffen
total scheiße
[Musik]
sagen sie der frau lagarde sie soll
endlich mal ihre geldpolitik ein
bisschen ändern und auch die zinspolitik
dann also dort glaube ich muss was
geändert werden unsere regierung ist
erstens zurzeit geschäftsführende wird
nicht allzu viel tun können aber auf
europäischer ebene auf der ezb geben
muss unbedingt was getan
[Musik]
und wir schalten jetzt zu unserem
kollegen michael deutsch man in dresden
an einer tankstelle denn wir wollen
wissen mit welchen gefühlen tanken die
menschen denn da an der zapfsäule
michael du kannst uns diese frage
beantworten ja guten morgen nach berlin
ich vermute mal und so ging es mir
nämlich gerade mit der geballten faust
in der tasche tanken am mittlerweile wir
haben mal für 50 euro ich kann es
vielleicht mal versuchen zu zeigen 50
euro getankt 50 eur 31 er einer
tankstelle an der bautzner straße in
dresden und von diesen 50 eur 31 sind
wunderbar ausgewiesen auf dem bon allein
26 eur 42 nur mineralölsteuer und dann
kommen noch mal dazu acht euro 3
mehrwertsteuer also über die hälfte von
dem schritt den ich da jetzt rein
geführt habe in mein auto ist alleine
das was der staat wegnimmt insofern ja
klar muss der staat jetzt reagieren das
meiste was den preis treibt ist das was
der staat einkassiert co2 steuern
mehrwertsteuer mineralölsteuer und das
macht die leute natürlich hier sauer wir
haben uns früh wie gesagt die ganze zeit
gefragt und mit den leuten gesprochen
und es gab ganz wenige die dafür
verständnis hatten selbst leute die im
elektroauto vor gefahren sondern einfach
nur luft aufgepumpt haben gesagt na ja
so wirklich so weitergehen kann das
nicht hier muss was passieren
die frage ist wer tut es und dann wird
es getan so lange wie die
koalitionsverhandlungen laufen und die
regierung nur geschäftsführend im amt
ist das haben die leute ja auch in der
regel relativ klar gesagt wird da nichts
passieren
die hoffnung ist also relativ klein dass
sich die dinge zum besseren wenden danke
michael noch mal ganz kurz aktuell der
blick da auf deine sprit tafel wo steht
aktuell hoch gucken ja der preis mein
kamerad ja wir haben es jetzt den diesel
bei 1 63 und super plus 1 97 das sind
natürlich mondpreise im übrigen das
möchte ich auch mal als wir hierher
gekommen sind heute morgen um 8 war da
diese noch bei 153 das sind zehn cent
inzwischen innerhalb der letzten zwei
stunden der preis gestiegen das macht
wirklich keinen spaß mehr also ernsthaft
ja total ärgerlich hinter dir steht es
da oben total wütend macht das die
meisten autofahrer danke michael mein
moment werden 1 nur noch sagen dann klar
ich habe mit der chefin von der
tankstelle gesprochen mit freut sich
kennen die sehr gut wohl nie um die ecke
also hier gehen ganz viele leute hin und
sie auch mal schnell zigaretten oder
kaufen stellen cafés zur arbeit geht die
frau kann am wenigsten dafür die sagt
ich kriege einen cent pro liter einen
cent egal wie hoch der preis ist und
habe nichts davon und kriegt trotzdem
ein ärgernis also sie kriegt den ärger
ab genau die wut der autofahrer muss
sich dafür verteidigen aber in wahrheit
hält der staat natürlich die hand
ordentlich auf neben dem russischen
danke michael für den moment dort nach
dresden vielen dank und wir sprechen mit
dem chefvolkswirt der commerzbank jörg
krämer darüber ob diese immer steigenden
preise auch weiter steigen also bleibt
uns die inflation schönen guten tag herr
krämer bleibt die
also erst noch mal mit eur vermutlich
weiter hoch gehen das könnte sein dass
wir im november
50 haben wenn die energiepreise weiter
so anziehen wie bisher nach der
jahreswende rechne ich damit dass die
inflation wieder runterkommt ball
sondern fakt wie der zwischenzeitliche
jeder anstieg der mehrwertsteuer weil
das wegfällt und auch die korona pante
wie sich lockert aber ich glaube am ende
wird sich die inflation auf einem niveau
ein schwingen was höher ist als jetzt
also ich bin anders ist viele andere
ökonomen indem ich sage wir sollten
diese
inflationsprobleme diese
inflationsrisiken nicht kleinreden die
sind da insbesondere wenn sie weiter
rausschauen und mehr die zukunft schon
was kann denn da die nächste regierung
also die ampel gegen die teuerung machen
die ampel kann nicht viel machen an der
installation die inflation nicht daran
dass die energie weltweit teurer
geworden ist dass mehrwertsteuer thema
ist nächstes jahr durch da kann der
anteil wenig machen am ende kommt es auf
die europäische zentralbank an also wenn
die ampel irgendwas machen kann da kann
sie ihren einfluss geltend machen dass
die europäische zentralbank
beginnt auszusteigen aus der sehr
lockeren geldpolitik dass sie nicht
weiter in großem stil staatsanleihen
kauft wenn dadurch gelangt zu viel geld
in die wirtschaft und das stellt ein
inflationsrisiko dar für die kommenden
jahre wenn wir jetzt auf die ezb zählen
müssen dann können wir lange warten oder
ja die europäische zentralbank achtet
natürlich schon auf die inflation aber
sie spielt eben auch auf die
hochverschuldeten länder im euroraum
gerade aus dem süden der währungsunion
da haben wir italien was ich doch der
den notwendigen tiefgreifenden reformen
verweigert und stattdessen rufen dann
viele länder im süden nach einer politik
des billigen geldes und trage diese rufe
rein in die ezb über ihre vertreter im
ezb rat und ja das feld die ezb zurück
weil andere zentralbanken wie
amerikanische werden bald beschließen
ihre anleihekäufe zurückzufahren die
britische zentralbank wird bald ihre
leitzinsen sogar anheben
noch mal die frage was können wir denn
alle was können wir gegen die teuerung
machen
man muss halt sagen wir vernünftig
aushalten das weiße jeder und mehr kann
man dagegen nicht machen und ich hoffe
halt darauf dass die ezb am ende ein
einsehen hat und die leitzinsen anhebt
weil eine normalisierung der geldpolitik
das ist das beste rezept dagegen dass
diese gegenwärtig hohe inflation zu
einem dauerhaften problem wird danke an
commerzbank experte jörg krämer zu der
immer weiter ja uns beschäftigen
inflation über diesen teuer hammer hier
in deutschland danke für das gespräch
und das wollen wir weiter vertiefen
ihrem studium mit bildpolitik chef jan
schäfer hallo hallo inflation und kein
ende in sicht und keiner hilft uns auch
uns zu entlasten richtig das ist richtig
und jörg krämer hat es gerade
angesprochen es gibt zwei stellschrauben
einig das ist zum einen schon die
regierung also die regierung trägt ja
über beispielsweise steuererhöhungen
oder überhaupt hohe steuersätze beim
sprit haben wir es gesehen aber es gibt
eine schaumweinsteuer auf alkoholische
getränke beispielsweise trägt schon dazu
bei dass dinge teurer werden kassiert
über die mehrwertsteuer 19 prozent
zusätzlich ab und dann gibt es natürlich
die europäische zentralbank frau lagarde
madame inflation muss man sagen das ist
die dame die in frankfurt sitzt und das
leben für uns teuer macht die die renten
schmilzt die die löhne schmilzt weil sie
eben die zinsen nicht erhöht und wir
wissen zinserhöhungen sind das beste und
wirksamste mittel gegen inflation so ist
es angelegt auch bei der europäischen
zentralbank und frau lagarde verweigert
sich wenn wir über die ampel gesprochen
also warum wird nichts getan andere
länder tun es ja auch die unterstützen
arme haushalte
absolut richtig wir brauchen eigentlich
jetzt ein antiker schwur der ampel und
da muss es darum gehen beispielsweise
steuern zu senken beispielsweise die
ökosteuer auf benzin oder auch eine
schaumweinsteuer von einer flasche sekt
beispielsweise fließt ein euro direkt
als schaumweinsteuer in die staatskasse
sind rund 370 83 millionen pro jahr also
da lässt sich durchaus etwas machen und
das zweite glaube ich was ganz wichtig
ist neben so einem anti teuer schwur
dass das ist einfach dass das
verständnis auch oder der schwur das
auch bei den sozialabgaben nicht weiter
drauf gesattelt werden darf bin
persönlich gegen gutscheine weil das
rechte tasche linke tasche ist die
bürger zahlen steuern und dann wird das
geld über ein gutschein wieder
zurückgegeben ich glaube dass man viel
direkter beim thema steuersenkung
ansetzen muss und beispielsweise auch
bei abgaben wir reden heute so vertieft
über dieses thema weil wir eben auch
sagen da passiert gerade nichts wir
werden gar nicht regiert warum ist das
so die einen könnten doch noch ein
bisschen zumindest und die anderen
können noch nicht wer wer ist da im
moment am meisten gefragt also wenn du
heute fordert es muss was gemacht werden
an wen richtet du dass das richtig
natürlich an die künftige regierung
dieser antiker schwur den muss muss die
ampel aufsetzen olaf scholz christian
lindner annalena baerbock aber du hast
ja auch nach versäumnissen gefragt und
das ist ganz klar ein versonnenes dieser
teuer schock auch der regierung von
angela merkel
es ist nichts passiert in den
vergangenen jahren beim thema
steuersenkungen im gegenteil wir haben
mittlerweile beim benzinpreis 66 prozent
die an den staat fließen dieses preises
also die regierung merkel auch mit ihrem
wirtschaftsminister peter altmaier mit
ihrem finanzminister olaf scholz hat das
thema inflation
komplett verschlafen es gab natürlich in
den vergangenen jahren auch gar nicht so
starke preissteigerungen aber es gab
auch gar nicht den mut zu sagen
vielleicht droht uns da etwas und wir
müssen vorsorge betreiben nein dass es
nicht passiert deswegen ist das was wir
sehen auch ein ganz klares versäumnis
der regierung merkel bleibt zu hoffen
dass da jetzt was passiert ist an den
richtigen schrauben auch rechtzeitig
gedreht wird ganz konkret auch dein tipp
an alle menschen da draußen die sie
jetzt unsere berichte sehen und sich
sagen um gottes willen ich heute will
heute noch tanken danach will ich im
supermarkt worauf muss man jetzt
besonders achten muss man besonders
vorsichtig jetzt gerade sein wenn man
den geldbeutel eröffnet naja es gibt
wenig möglichkeiten inflation zu
entfliehen und deswegen ist inflation
noch das unsozialste was es gibt ich
wunder mich immer über ökonomen die
sagen ja ein bisschen inflation der
sinnvollen ein inflation bedeutet immer
von 1000 euro lohn oder rente habe ich
am ende unterm strich weniger und bei
4,5 prozent inflation sind das bei 1000
euro 45 euro weniger für die ich mir
etwas kaufen kann und es sind viele
menschen angewiesen auf das auto sie
sind angewiesen darauf benzin zu kaufen
lebensmittel zu kaufen die wohnung zu
heizen da ist nicht viel möglich um zu
sparen aber natürlich könnte man sagen
kann des abends als in der nacht oder
morgens ganz klar da gibt es ja auch
dann preisunterschiede aber am ende hat
der verbraucher nicht viele chancen
eigentlich auszuweichen er kann nur
weniger konsumiert